le 19/20 continue voici le rappel des
titres non à la confiscation de notre
révolution alors qu'en rda deux partis
d'opposition sont déjà prêts à claquer
la porte
la jeunesse roumaine lance un cri du
coeur plusieurs manifestations à sibiu
et à craiova pour protester contre le
maintien d'anciens collaborateurs de ces
housses et ce coût aux postes de
responsabilité le général noriega
désormais entre les mains de la justice
américaine inculpé pour trafic de drogue
il risque de terminer sa vie en prison
une transplantation cardiaque
exceptionnelle à l'hôpital de lyon une
greffe du coeur pratiqués sur un nouveau
né
seulement âgé de deux jours enfin léger
tremblement de terre dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
certains accusent les gisements de gaz
l'enquète à la fin de ce journal
mais tout de suite le point sur un fait
divers sordide en haute savoie à
l'assassinât d'une jeune fille de 14 ans
à coups de barre de fer dans un entrepôt
désaffecté de la rochefort les gendarmes
ont rapidement identifié l'auteur
présumé de ce meurtre ce dernier a
proches de la victime a été ce soir
inculpés et écroués de grenoble jean
louis vaissière aussitôt l'enquêté s'est
orientée sur les fréquentations d'agnès
dans le quartier du plain château où
elle a passé son enfance
les gens l'aimaient bien mais ils
reprochaient aussi certains de ses amis
peu recommandable le soir du crime
agnès est resté dans un bar où elle
venait parfois le sixties à 22h30
l'établissement fermé à nier c'est parti
avec les autres on ne devait plus la
revoir vivante la gendarmerie entendu
tous les clients en début d'après-midi
alors que l'un d'entre eux était en
garde à vue le juge d'instruction nous a
fait cette déclaration
probablement il ya eu des aspects de
perversion bord de barbarie enfin le top
6 et les résultats de l'autopsié ont en
tout cas le révèle le suspect numéro 1
et johan blot qui est âgé de 22 ans a
été inculpé d'assassinât avec tortures
et actes de barbarie
le meurtrier présumé connaissait sa
victime il n'a donné aucune précision
sur le déroulement des faits une enquête
rapidement bouclé par les gendarmes peu
un prolongement dans les milieux de la
drogue de la roche sur foron la victime
pourrait en avoir consommé ainsi que son
meurtrier
il ya donc derrière cette affaire un
vrai problème de société
à l'étranger le général noriega devant
les tribunaux américains l'ancien
dictateur panaméen est arrivé cet
après-midi aux etats-unis après cette
porte est prisonnier la nuit dernière
non sans avoir reçu la suprême assurance
que ses jours ne seraient jamais en
danger
en revanche le dictateur déchu risque de
terminer sa vie en prison puisqu'il fait
l'objet de nombreuses inculpation pour
trafic de drogue
une victoire désormais totale pour le
président américain george bush
victoire aussi pour le peuple panaméen
morad aït habbouche grâce à une caméra
infrarouge voici les pilotes d'un long
feuilleton à rebondissements cette nuit
un hélicoptère américain à quelques
mètres de la nonciature d'école à
l'intérieur le général noriega a pris
place transfert discret à la base
militaire de word ou face d'ananas et
arrêtés par la brigade américaine
antidrogue
c'est fini l'ex dictateur s'est rendu de
son plein gré ce matin le vatican a
confirmé cette information
sur la base de homestead en floride le
comité d'accueil armée de casseroles
reçoit l'homme à l'origine de leur exil
forcé leur slogan unique
abba noriega mission accomplie pour
george bush en dépit des 24 jia est hué
lors des combats et des centaines de
victimes panaméenne
le président américain est satisfait son
opération juste cause a réussi
satisfaction également sur place
explosion de joie partout dans le pays
guillermo endara le chef d'état a même
parlé de jours glorieux
notre pays vit tranquille désormais at
il dit le monstre est parti du panama
mais s'il ne gêne plus dans son pays
il risque bien embarrassé les états unis
son procès un avant-goût sulfureux
inculpé de trafic de drogue
il pourrait compromettre quelques
politiciens américains certains
murmurent le nom de george bush entre
autres qui a été directeur de la cia à
l'époque où noriega était un informateur
privilégié
il est vrai qu'à ce moment là face
d'ananas était encore en odeur de
sainteté
la situation post révolutionnaire en
europe de l'est alors qu'en rda deux
partis d'opposition sont déjà prêts à
claquer la porte en roumanie les
étudiants sont les premiers à manifester
leur inquiétude vis-à-vis de l'évolution
politique de la situation dans leur pays
ils le crient au gouvernement cette
révolution est la nôtre ne l'a
confisquée pas cette fois la télévision
roumaine n'a diffusé aucune image oui
tandis que les partis politiques
continuent à se créer l approche des
élections
une partie de la population exprime de
plus en plus sa méfiance à l'égard des
hommes au pouvoir aujourd'hui
après l'euphorie passée comme en rda le
peuple réclame davantage de garanties
d'autant plus que la polémique autour du
conseil du front de salut national
continue jérôme cathala
même si les roumains sont avant tout à
la recherche de la paix civile
ils veulent tout de même savoir savoir
qui les gouvernent actuellement savoir
ce qu'il va advenir de leur révolution
alors les langues se délient un peu
aurillac à bas coûts journaliste au
journal libertatea la liberté a donc
décidé de nous apporter son témoignage
c'est un habitant de gouvernement juste
par autoriser de vos dire son nom
il ya cinq ou six ans il m'a dit qu'il
ya une organisation politique et qu'ils
ont besoin d'un journaliste alors une
certain organisations politiques ou
plusieurs organisations politiques
contre ses rochers sco existait la
révolution sous une forme ou une autre
était donc bien prévu même le vice
président du conseil du front de salut
national là vous il est allé lui-même en
union soviétique demandé l'appui de
gorbatchev un éventuel renversement de
ceausescu
les soviétiques ont promis de nous aider
mais sans enthousiasme tout cela
inquiète ou provoque la colère de
certains roumains les jeunes notamment
qui aurait donc manifesté hier à sibiu
et à craiova mais aussi tous ceux qui
créent ou recréer des partis politiques
en vue des élections d'avril
le parti national paysans ou le parti
national libéral ces deux formations ont
d'ailleurs décidé de se présenter
ensemble contre les actuels dirigeants
les autres télégramme de l'étranger
préparer et commenté ce soir par
marie-odile panier
les mots nazis dehors non retour du
troisième reich
les cris de dizaines de milliers
d'allemands de l'est venus manifester
hier soir à berlin contre le renouveau
fasciste la semaine dernière des groupes
néo-nazis ont couvert de slogans
racistes plusieurs monuments du pays
210 morts et 700 blessés le pakistan a
connu cette nuit la plus grave
catastrophe ferroviaire de son histoire
un train transportant 1500 passagers a
heurté de plein fouet un convoi de
marchandises arrêté en gare sur la même
voie la collision serait due à une
erreur de signalisation les côtes
marocaines épargné par la marée noire
reste maintenant à trouver un port
d'accueil au pétrolier iranien afin de
transborder les quelques 200000 tonnes
de pétrole brut qui reste dans ses
soutes les espagnols sollicité se
montrent réticents le cargo 5 laissant
encore échapper une partie de sa
cargaison
en australie la vague de chaleur
exceptionnelle que connaît le pays a
provoqué de nombreux incendies plus de
mille pompiers luttent contre les feux
de broussailles mais une vingtaine de
villes restent menacées par les flammes
et leurs habitants ont été évacués
l'accident du pétrolier iranien cargo 5
dont nous venons de parler met une fois
de plus en lumière le comportement
inqualifiable des compagnies qu'ils
considèrent trop souvent la mère comme
la poubelle de la société industrielle
nouvel exemple sur les côtes de bretagne
après la tempête du mois dernier
et vous voyez à l'île-grande à côté de
perros guirec sur un millier d'oiseaux
mazoutés seule une centaine ont été
recueillis en effet pendant la dernière
tempête au large des côtes de bretagne
de nombreux bateaux en ont profité pour
dégazer c'est-à-dire vider le contenu de
leur qg en r2 les mêmes des phoques les
bouleversements en europe de l'est et
leurs répercussions sur la construction
communautaire c'est le thème central des
entretiens aujourd'hui entre françois
mitterrand et helmut kohl un débat sur
le fond dans un cadre de détente filiale
est chez la maison de campagne
hollandaise de françois mitterrand un
cadre où les deux hommes se sont mis
d'accord sur la nécessité de renforcer
la cee et de créer à terme je cite une
confédération européenne qui puisse
accueillir d'autres pays d'europe ayant
récemment renoué avec la démocratie
une transplantation cardiaque
exceptionnelle à l'hôpital cardiologique
de lyon une greffe du coeur sur un
nouveau né
alors qu'il était âgé seulement de deux
jours sans cette opération ce jeune
garçon n'aurait pas survécu au delà de
quelques jours 8 jouera donc après cette
intervention un révélé seulement
aujourd'hui le nouveau né se portent
bien
le reportage de nos confrères de dieu
une échographie avant naissance avait
permis de diagnostiquer une malformation
cardiaque
généralement mortel chez ce petit garçon
le bébé de 2 kilos 800 souffrait d'une
hypoplasie du coeur gauche en clair il
lui manquait la moitié du coeur et
l'aorte
le petit jean yves à peine âgé de deux
jours a donc subi une transplantation
cardiaque à l'hôpital de cardiologie
cette opération exceptionnelle a été
réalisée par l'équipe du professeur
gérard champsaur et du docteur jeanine
et le coeur et la horde de remplacement
ont été prélevés sur un nouveau né
six jours en coma dépassé aujourd'hui
huit jours après l'intervention
jean yves qui est soumis à un traitement
anti rejet se porte bien il a un éveil
normale et a même été libéré de toute
assistance respiratoire
ni chauffage ni cantine pour certains
écoliers de montfermeil le conseil
municipal voulait les priver des droits
par un mot élémentaire sous le prétexte
qu'ils sont des enfants d'immigrés oui
pour la deuxième fois en deux mois le
tribunal administratif de paris a
repoussé la date d'exécution de la
décision du conseil municipal de
montfermeil
le point avec christine lenief c'est un
désaveu pour pierre bernard maire de
montfermeil pas une condamnation le
tribunal administratif de paris
appelé en référé c'est à dire en
jugement d'urgence a demandé à pierre
bernard de surseoir à exécution de la
décision de son conseil municipal
c'est un nouveau délai accordé mais pas
une véritable opposition aux mesures
prises par les élus locaux pour freiner
l'immigration la ville de montfermeil
s'attaque aux enfants d'immigrés en
interdisant aux deux écoles maternelle
de la cité des bosquets de les inscrire
le préfet en vertu de son pouvoir de
substitution a autorisé les deux
directrices concernés à accueillir ces
enfants
c'est alors que pierre bernard et son
conseil municipal ont décidé de couper
le chauffage et la cantine des deux
établissements la date elle est à chaque
fois repoussées par le tribunal
administratif
je voudrais bien
exécuter ce jugement en ne comprenant
d'un autre côté je suis légaliste le 6
et le conseil municipal
c'est une assemblée et démocratiquement
élu par le peuple donc qui a une valeur
le très grand m'a donné des ordres
contraires je pense donc je vais réunir
mon conseil municipal et lui demander l
attitude que devra prendre la ville de
montfermeil
au travers de son conseil vieillard à
une contradiction juridique est très
nette
le conseil municipal se réunira en début
de semaine prochaine
en attendant sa décision les
associations antiracistes manifesteront
demain à montfermeil 20 millions de
francs d'indemnités pour les
ostréiculteurs de l'étang de thau
décisions annoncées par jacques mellick
le ministre de la mer au titre de la
solidarité nationale à l'égard des
conchyliculteurs victimes de
l'interdiction de commercialiser leurs
huîtres vous le savez atteintes de
salmonelle alors après la tempête le
calme semble être revenu sur l'étang de
thau feu les 800 conquis les cultes
heures et leurs familles touchées par
cette interdiction attendent maintenant
la réouverture de la commercialisation
elle pourrait intervenir dans une
dizaine de jours de montpellier paul
rené dignité cette limpidité des eaux de
l'étang de thau n'était qu'apparence le
dialogue noué hier à paris entre le
ministre de la mer et les ostréiculteurs
aura permis au moins de clarifier sur ce
point les positions des uns et des
autres et conquis les cultes heures pour
leur part se disent prêts à tout faire
pour effacer pour le présent et pour
l'avenir toute pollution de leur bassin
avec l'aide des pouvoirs publics quant
aux mesures d'être immédiate
bien qu'elle ne fasse pas l'unanimité
elles sont prises en compte par les
ostréiculteurs
si les collectivités locales font un
sérieux fort l'état aurait pu
notre avis
à l'esc a doublé une des priorités
actuellement c'est de réhabiliter un
produit qui a été dénigré de toute façon
ajustements et
pendant les mois à venir ça sera la
chanson à laquelle il faudra travailler
les sérieusement demain professionnels
et élus se retrouveront à la préfecture
de montpellier où avec le directeur de
cabinet du ministre de la mer y mettrons
au point dans le détail l'articulation
des accords conclus hier soir à paris
19h47 voici à présent le tour de france
de l'actualité avec les images des 25
stations à 3 et les commentaires de ce
figuier
évasion manqué hier soir à la maison
d'arrêt de nice à 18 heures un détenu
lance une corde au dessus du mur
d'enceinte met le grappin lâche et un
habitant du quartier témoin de la scène
alertent les gardiens de prisonniers
malchanceux n'est pas un inconnu
il s'appelle nicolas bouge membre d'un
parti d'extrême droite il est accusé
d'avoir participé aux attentats racistes
contre les foyers sonacotra entre 86 et
88 visite houleuse pour brice lalonde
aujourd'hui sur le site de montchanin
cette décharge désaffecté qui contient
un million de tonnes de déchets malgré
des propos apaisants
le secrétaire d'état à l'environnement
n'a pas réussi à rassurer les habitants
il s'est déclaré contre l'évacuation
totale des déchets quant à l'affirmation
du magazine politis concernant la
présence de fûts de toxines
monsieur lalonde la qualifier de canular
c'est un véritable arsenal de guerre qui
a été découvert à marée basse à soulac
sur les côtes d'aquitaine 137 obus
allemands enfui sous le sable depuis 45
ans les obus qui peuvent encore explosé
les services de déminage de la sécurité
civile sont donc venus les récupérer cet
après midi ils seront détruites dans les
prochains jours
il est chinois est hélas dans 50 ans
mais problème cet arbre vénérable
s'élève à l'endroit où devait être
construite une école pas question pour
autant de le détruire la commune d'albi
n'y a donc trouvé la solution elle a
construit sa maternelle autour de
l'arbre ce sera sans doute la première
école buissonnière au pied de la lettre
un léger tremblement de terre la nuit
dernière dans la région de pau aucun
dégât heureusement n'a été constaté mais
en 20 ans ce sont au total près de 800
secousses telluriques qui ont été
constatés dans cette région alors
aujourd'hui certains spécialistes
considèrent que ces secousses sont tout
à fait artificielle et qu'elles
cesseront dans deux ou trois ans d'être
à laquelle fermeront les gisements de
gaz de la région de bordeaux jacques de
bord on n'a toujours pas déterminé
l'épicentre de cette dernière secousse
mais ici arthez de béarn à quelques
kilomètres de là qu elle a été
particulièrement ressentie au robot et
après ceux de soutien la secousse au
procédé très vite fait et à quelques
kilomètres de là certaines personnes en
revanche n'ont rien ressenti
en vingt ans on a enregistré ainsi 800
secousses de 1 à 4 2 sur l'échelle de
richter
et tout cela eh bien c'est la faute à
l'exploitation du gisement de lacq halak
elle fait trembler la terre titre la
revue scientifique science et vie junior
qui présente les travaux d'étude d'un
géophysicien de grenoble jean robert
grasso pour lui il s'agit de séismes
artificielle lèche la chute de pression
du gisement de gaz et le paramètre
majeur dans cette chute de pression se
transmet au milieu environnant par des
variations de force et le milieu répond
comme une éponge qui dégonfle sont là
les terrains environnants ont à se
réajuster si c'était vrai sens
suffisamment souple ils vont se déformer
on enregistre alors une petite un petit
affaissement surface ces terrains sont
plus raides la face à l'affaissement
surface sera plus faible
par contre ils risquent de casser ce
train
et de recherche avait été demandé par le
ministère de l'industrie en 1980 mais
elf aquitaine préfère encore garder le
silence aujourd'hui
et puis pour terminer ce journal la mise
en garde de france télécom auprès de ses
abonnés des télex et télécopie contre
des fausses factures des documents qui
imitent les factures de france télécom
et qui vont même jusqu'à imiter son logo
reportage de pascal ceaux pouces facture
attention danger si vous êtes une
entreprise de la région prenez garde à
la réception de vos notes de téléphone
30 sociétés tout un plan à l'étranger
inondent le marché de faux documents
c'est par la télécopie qu'ils arrivent
en apparence rien ne les distingue des
vrais regardez bien
d'abord une vraie facture est tout de
suite derrière une fausse les mêmes
couleurs le même format est presque le
même sigle si vous ne faites pas
attention vous payez en toute confiance
croyant régler votre note de téléphone
erreur ce système de fausse facturation
se développe depuis deux ou trois ans un
comble aujourd'hui même les télécoms en
reçoivent
et il porte plainte à nous réalisons
parce que nous sommes chargés d'un
service public
il n'est pas normal qu'il y ait de
telles exactions soient compétitives
termes qui soient faites en imitant ce
service public
et puis que nous ne chantons une
certaine responsabilité vie de nos
abonnés suprême habileté les factures
n'excède jamais un montant de 4000 prend
du coup les victimes hésitent à porter
plainte pour une si petite somme
france télécom s'en est chargé mais la
procédure sera longue
en attendant mesdames les secrétaires
regardez il ya deux fois avant de régler
la note
havas l'instant la météo complète de
michel touré ce soit un programme
spécialement conçu pour catherine
matausch avec un excellent film avatar
tran l'éternel docteur jivago et puis
vous retrouverez philippe dessaint à
23h45 pour soir 3 demain le 19 ans vous
sera représentée par gérard pinson élise
lucet nous vous retrouverons lundi
excellente soirée à tous qu'on fasse
m
mais m